[Music]
Olympic athletes defy gravity and
impress audiences around the world but
many struggle financially on the road to
those games the US Olympic Committee a
nonprofit reported 339 million dollars
in revenue back in 2016 and the
International Olympic Committee makes
billions of dollars from broadcasting
rights and sponsorship deals Dana
Jacobson is in Pyeongchang South Korea
with a look at the financial burden at
some of the athletes face in pursuit of
their Olympic dreams Dana I hear it's
costly a good morning good morning that
it is an Olympic athlete will tell you
you can't put a price tag on the Olympic
experience but there is a cost to
getting here take those who have to
crowdfund online just to pay for some of
their training or to get their family to
Pyeongchang now there is a small group
of athletes who get rich in their quest
for Olympic glory but for others there
is a harsh reality and it's like driving
a car on oil on oil really fast really
fast with guardrails around for Team USA
loser chris master riding really fast
has paid off here in Pyeongchang it's
awesome to say we did it and thank you
he won silver in individual men's luge
becoming the first American man to ever
medal in the event but it almost didn't
happen you a couple weeks ago thought I
know I'd have to get out of the sport
exactly I wanted to stay into it for
another four years but the thought of
staying in the sport without being able
to make anything or to be able to give
back just even pay rent is it's a really
serious thing that people don't know
exists while he savors the victory he
remembers the struggle I was a bartender
work banquets restaurants so it's a
fight to get to that level but if you're
as committed like you'll do anything how
big of a disparity is there between
Winter Olympic athletes
well huge Patrick Quinn is an agent
representing several athletes at the
games when you talk about an extreme of
a Lindsey Vonn and a Sean Whyte and the
vast majority of the Olympians
it's a whole different world it's first
class to coach for sure unlike many
other countries the US federal
government does not fund Olympic
programs in 1978 Congress turned over
the job of representing American
athletes to the US Olympic Committee a
non-profit loser Chris Mader has been
successful enough to get free housing in
an Olympic Training Center you have to
get to that level but you're not really
making any money the USOC doles out
money using a pay-for-performance model
athletes and sports that are most likely
to win medals get the most money coming
from a small sport I think when it does
come down to the finances yeah there is
a little bit of jealousy just because
you feel like you're putting in a
similar amount of effort but you don't
receive the same back and I think the
reason you stay in lose is because
you're passionate about it in its latest
annual report the USOC says ninety-three
percent of its revenue goes to support
Olympic and Paralympic athletes 2008
Olympian van Barger a former member of
the USO sees athletes Advisory Council
estimates that just six percent reaches
athletes pockets in the form of direct
payments when asked if this figure was
correct the USOC
said no but would not provide another
number Barger told CBS News the US
Congress should review what he calls the
financial strategy and waste of the USOC
for athletes who fund their own way
sponsors can be a big source of
financial help but the IOC s rule 40
puts restrictions on brands that don't
also sponsor the games you can't use the
word Olympic you can't use gold or
silver 2018 how new athletes work their
sponsors if they're not Olympic sponsors
it's challenging and gets complicated
use this word and you can't do it at
this time and that sort of thing while
the rules have been relaxed a US ski
jumper tweeted his frustration saying
the sponsorship ban makes it quote hard
for the little guy to make money or even
just support themselves
I do compliment the USOC they do a
tremendous amount of bringing sponsors
in to support as many athletes
but the reality is they can't fund all
of the athletes that need the funding
and so some of the rules have actually
been relaxed as for loozer chris master
he's pondering a future as a financial
planner but he's not giving up his sled
just yet a few weeks ago you didn't know
if you would continue financially what
does that silver medal mean now this
silver medal right here says I'm going
another four years and it also gives me
the ability first off to say thank you
but to be able to give back because I
understand the struggle I've been there
for many many years master said that
while he wasn't always rewarded
financially for his sport he was paid in
life experience things he would not have
gotten to do otherwise and as he moves
forward he'll have a little help along
the way Patrick Quinn the agent who we
spoke with will now be working with him
we should point out that we reached out
to the International Olympic Committee
for comment on our story they referred
us to the USOC John Danny Jacobsen and
Jung Chang a really interesting story
yeah it seems like they should be able
to make some kind of a living while
trying to compete for the United States
of America especially because it's a
dream can you imagine that you know you
have the talent you just want somebody
to believe in you please send money well
maybe now more well yeah